we've got breaking news about the duke  of york this is prince andrew we haven't  seen him  today and that is possibly because he  has tested positive for covid and we are  being told he will no longer attend the  jubilee service of thanksgiving at  support cathedral tomorrow morning this  is coming from buckingham palace we have  thought that if we were going to see the  duke of york at any point this weekend  during these celebrations it would be at  supports cathedral tomorrow but we now  understand he has tested positive for  covid so will not be attending that's  the duke of york testing positive for  coded and missing the celebrations the  family gathering you would imagine as  well behind closed doors